hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et tu table le styliste dû
cliquer sur démarrer pour que notre
aventure commence je t'attends rejoint
vite sur messenger
[Musique]
lorsque les séparer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et ça tombe bien j'ai compris c'est un
numéro de mime donc il peut pas parler
alors ils savent où aller me met des
choses
d'accord et on va essayer de trouver de
quoi il s'agit d'accord vous allez c'est
trouver quelques kilos me maïssa
attention merci gens vont déjà un
attendant les restos merci merci
alors vous allez nous lie mais à un
premier truc et s'est trouvée attention
s'ils voulaient vraiment faire cette
surprise à omar pas c'est tout simple
hein c'est juste un petit truc
[Musique]
ce qu'il a fait mais c'est tout s'était
passé
[Applaudissements]
cette enquête et nos tests c'était ma
tête oui d'ailleurs bientôt mais il a
ouvert la porte mais comme il le fait
bien
et ouais vous mais moi c est la petite
musique est vraiment très bien trouvé
beblawi les bouches au bout du rouleau
[Rires]
deuxième
non
[Musique]
tu leur cheval je m'adresse pas fini
besson oui il a 30 ans il apprend
quelque chose et voilà la preuve pas un
animal et le tube 0 c'était juste sa
marque a gonflé le jeu a tendance à elle
fait un prime que sur ceux de ses
valeurs alors sachez que ça va être la
nouvelle formule de motus attention 3e 3
des actions 10 a conduit moi je peux
faire ça tout cela les bouchons baisse
la vitre ivresse la voiture dans les
bouchons boudemaghe a sûrement besoin
d'argent chez vous pendant qu'on
installe à kamina bluff
attention attention
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
installé en moi attention les gars là
c'est très très dur
non mais j'ai dit lâche et vous essayez
de trouver je vous rappelle que vous
jouez pour la la modique somme la
modique somme qu'on attendait voisinage
à poissons c'est un second set à son nom
qui fait quoi
ironie rendu rencontre m et par la rue
de la rivière
[Applaudissements]
un dernier regard ni aidé à vélo et il
est content vous allez vous avez reparlé
quand même ne remettra pas merci à
monsieur merci allez c'est parti on a
hâte